to help celebrate our 11 years of shows
at tbs we're putting together
montages of some of our favorite show
highlights
now anyone who knows me knows i am not a
fan of video games i
i don't play them and i'm really not
good at them at all
which is why i decided i was the perfect
person to review them
why not in a segment we call clueless
gamer
uh yeah here are uh
here are some of our best love clueless
gamer moments
conan o'brien here with another clueless
gamer
why do i fear the slender man he can
kill you are you scared right now
i would say is boredom count as scared
was this a european game
no no is it a european game i don't
think so because europeans
man they blow sometimes this is the
slenderman
it is an old folktale the slenderman
what does he do to children he takes
away their chestnuts
oh that's a european truck tell me
that's not some weird
dutch truck look at that that's a scrub
i knew the voice of this guy why would a
gondorian come here
and try to murder all of the orcs maybe
you have a problem with one orc you
didn't change your voice at all
you in no way changed your voice where
was that
you just wanted to just do some spare
lines from silicon valley and call it a
day
i don't see this ending well what are
you saying
i'm saying pied piper needs funding
you can design your own character i've
been hard at work at mine
and that's me
that's humiliating what an [ __ ]
oh i'm surprised i'm not shot right
hello i'm coming
hey remember when we were in that band
together weren't you a bass player
hey you want to go uh bug some people
down in venice
hey man listen you don't get it man
look i just got fired from amoeba all
right
can i wear my shirt to work look i did
your tattoos for you for free
oh i haven't done any of this by the way
no
this is let's see you at home know we
haven't touched the controller for 45
minutes
no no no no no no no okay okay dude
kick me out of a strip club i come back
with a missile firing truck
there it is ripple yeah
you got hit pretty hard i did yeah
playing the vikings
i wanted to show a video of you getting
tackled but nfl won't let us have the
footage
so uh the closest thing we can do is
show this simulation
of what happened to you take a look
all right and then there's samus isn't
this one of the guys from daft punk
so uh next is uh mark so these are all
from different games
yes yes it spans the the world of
nintendo do you know about all these
games
yes so you have you've got no life
you've put
all of your eggs into this basket all
right so greninja
is just his tongue and a scarf he's like
a kind of like a frog
quick who was our second president from
washington uh benjamin franklin he was
impressed he was never
president uh no no it was
uh you know all this [ __ ]
no no no no it was uh quick what's his
name
uh i mean there's a villager from animal
kingdom and who's that uh that's
from fire emblem that's marth okay
america just lost
you get to play yourself mm-hmm there
you are and
you're the same as me yeah mary i'm
getting moisturizer
okay this is exciting look at me i have
no fear
[Applause]
what the hell was that that's me after
three beers
oh my god this is fantastic so now we
gotta get across the street
get across the street i'm going across
the street here we go
crossing the street oh no
you know what they don't even slow down
when i've been hit get across the street
shut up here i go no
[Laughter]
get across the street stop saying that
i'm going
no i am not leaving this room till i get
across this street
i'm almost across oh
oh god oh this is the hardest thing i've
done in my life
you know oh get across the street
how do you run again get across the
street
yes yes wait a minute look at that
there's a bridge
that goes across the street there's a
pedestrian crossover
stupid idiot peter you are the winner
because it's game of thrones you will
now be presented with my head
on a spike by our george r.r martin
look alike
kind of me who
donald
i'm chasing tom brady
ah what what did i just do one
uh you just knocked tom brady off the
bridge
round three this decides it oh there you
go
now what the hell happened
this is mario kart version eight is that
right i don't know
we were thinking maybe we should add
like stakes to it like stakes to the
game like if the losers like something
happens if you lose like a college thing
like like people draw
[ __ ] on each other's faces like dicks
oh man
my own natural arm hair has created hair
look at that you're
[Music]
and it is rated e for everyone
this is where i struggle with rpgs
because it's a lot of just walking
around
i got no credit this is we're trapped in
a a beckett play
there's nothing there's nothing that's
going to happen we're waiting for things
that can't happen
this is an aggressive wasting of our
time
look at that thing is this
wow it's a really impressive beast
could have started the game with this
thing
tell me when something happens was that
it
that was the battle what did something
happen that's it sometimes
when you actually feel a sense of
accomplishment that was just to suss him
out
and then when you actually battle him it
takes three real days what's the point
of all this yeah
it seriously takes three real days
why would someone play this why didn't
someone play this game
the people who made the game are outside
and i didn't realize they're watching
this in real time they're actually
watching me now
complain viciously about the family
right behind that door
and here's the beauty the only way out
of the room
is through the floor the only way to get
to our car and
go back to our lives is through that
door and they're still watching
we have to face them this what's
happening now
is more thrilling than anything that
happened
hello you've been working on this game
for seven months
what's the purpose
babies will not be born because of you
crops
will not be brought in from the field
that said good job